[Musica]
questo è il mio libro di diritto privato
proprio il mio quello su cui ho studiato
istituzioni di diritto privato una delle
prime materie del piano di studi della
facoltà di giurisprudenza anche una
delle materie più difficili come vedete
un librone di 1.500 pagine così facciamo
subito fuori qualcuno in questo libro
uno dei primi capitoli era dedicato al
soggetto del rapporto giuridico ed era
distinto in una parte ha dedicato alla
persona fisica ed in una parte emili
dedicata alla persona giuridica come per
esempio le società ma nessun accenno
eppure un piccolo piccolo neppure nelle
note all'intelligenza artificiale certo
30 anni fa vero ma non mi risulta che la
situazione sia cambiata negli ultimi
anni di intelligenza artificiale ha
fatto dei grandi passi avanti e il
progredire dell'intelligenza artificiale
ha ovviamente portato con sé una serie
di quesiti
primo tra tutti può l'intelligenza
artificiale essere considerata al
soggetto di diritto
su questo argomento molte istituzioni
molti governi si stanno seriamente
interrogando nel 2020 ad esempio la
commissione europea ha pubblicato un
libro bianco in cui ha messo in evidenza
da un lato le potenzialità enormi
dell'intelligenza artificiale pensiamo
solo al settore sanitario e dall'altro
lato però ha messo in evidenza i rischi
potenzialmente devastanti che
l'intelligenza artificiale può portare
con se pensiamo al rischio di opacità
rischio di discriminazione è bastato sul
colore della pelle successo a rischio di
intrusione nella vita di ciascuno di noi
l'unione europea suggerisce quindi un
approccio di carattere etico ed
antropocentrico che tenga conto anche
dei valori fondanti dell'unione
quindi il 21 aprile 2021 la unione
europea ha avanzato una proposta di
regolamento volto a disciplinare i
sistemi di intelligenza artificiale si
tratta però ancora di una proposta e
quindi non è ancora entrata in vigore
dovrà essere discussa in parlamento
personalmente mi trovo molto d'accordo
su questo con questo approccio perché
credo che l'intelligenza artificiale
debba essere uno strumento per aiutare
l'uomo uno strumento nelle mani
dell'uomo ecco francamente nessuno sa
dove esattamente ci troviamo e come sarà
il futuro il futuro rimane un punto
interrogativo anche gli stessi
scienziati e gli ingegneri informatici
sono non sono del tutto d'accordo tra di
loro così secondo alcuni ma non secondo
tutti l'intelligenza artificiale
oggi già oggi è in grado di creare
autonomamente e dovreste un fatto che
l'intelligenza artificiale abbia già
scritto delle poesie abbia scritto degli
articoli di giornale abbia realizzato
autonomamente dei quadri pensiamo il
famoso caso dell'autoritratto di
rembrandt gli stessi studiosi di
rembrandt a hanno ammesso che avrebbero
avuto difficoltà a non attribuire
l'autoritratto generato
dell'intelligenza artificiale a
rembrandt medesimo e l'intelligenza
artificiale compone anche delle musiche
ecco magari non siamo ancora la nona di
beethoven ma sicuramente l'intelligenza
artificiale crea questa situazione un po
di incertezza nei prossimi anni potrebbe
succedere che come avvocato mi si
presenta un potenziale cliente e mi
racconta di essere stato investito da
una macchina guidata da un intelligenza
artificiale
oppure di essere stato operato da un
robot guidato da un intelligenza
artificiale ma l'operazione è andata
male bisogna bisogna fare causa
ma a chi faccio causa chi è responsabile
di questa situazione
i problemi da avvocato d'accordo però
non credo che si tratti solo di problemi
per noiosi giuristi per accademici in
cerca di pubblicità o per pensatori i
nerd
la verità è che ci avete pensato quel
cliente potrebbe essere ciascuno di noi
però l'intelligenza artificiale promette
progresso ma quando inizia il progresso
quando ho iniziato questo viaggio ecco
facciamo un po un salto indietro nel
tempo e l'uomo fin dalle sue origini
capisce che scagliare una pietra è meno
efficace di tirare una lancia
e poi capisce che scagliare quella
stessa lancia ma con un arco consente
alla lancia di arrivare più lontano di
arrivare più dritto all'obiettivo
quindi possiamo dire che l'uomo fin
dalle sue origini
intuisce immagina crea a volte per caso
fino a quando fino a quando nel vii
secolo avanti cristo a sibari una
colonia della magna grecia un cuoco
inventa una ricetta nuova ed originale e
il legislatore del tempo attribuisce al
cuoco un diritto di esclusiva su quella
ricetta per un anno
ecco certo dovremo ancora poi aspettare
tanti secoli prima di avere una
legislazione organica in materia di
brevetti dove nasce questa legislazione
nasce in america nasce in francia e gran
bretagna 1474 serenissima repubblica di
venezia il primo statuto dei brevetti
grazie al quale il legislatore
dell'epoca conferisce all'inventore di
una cosa nuova ed originale un diritto
di esclusiva per dieci anni poi verrà la
legge inglese poi verrà la legge
americana solo sul finire del 1700 con
la francese ecco ma cos'è esattamente un
brevetto un brevetto è un patto che lo
stato fa con l'inventore calo inventore
vuoi una esclusiva sulla tua idea nuova
ed originale bene ti do questa esclusiva
per 20 anni
ma a patto che tu mi dica sin da subito
qual è la tua idea che tu me la descrive
nel dettaglio in modo tale che alla fine
dei vent'anni chiunque possa replicare
la tua idea la tua idea cadrà nella
tecnica comune andrà a far parte del
patrimonio tecnico collettivo di modo
tale che chiunque possa replicare la tua
invenzione quindi da un lato cioè un
incentivo all'inventore e dall'altro
lato però questa stessa o questo stesso
incentivo va poi a beneficio di tutta la
collettività perché il brevetto diventa
patrimonio di tutti
e quindi potrà costituire la base per
altri studi altre ricerche altri
brevetti
si calcola che nei prossimi 10 15 anni
la maggior parte del dei brevetti sarà
realizzata con l'ausilio di o
esclusivamente da l'intelligenza
artificiale e con quest'ultimo caso chi
sarà l'inventore chi sarà l'inventore
del brevetto fanta diritto nel 2018
ryanair voto un professore di diritto di
una università americana deposita due
domande di brevetto per due trovati che
a suo dire erano stati generati
autonomamente da un intelligenza
artificiale si trattava di due domande
luna relativa ad un particolare raggio
che consente di essere più facilmente
individuati al buio e l'altra relativa
ad un contenitore per alimenti a
geometria frattale che modifica la
propria forma durante il trasporto
dell'alimento queste due domande vengono
depositate presso numerosi uffici quello
americano con l'europeo quello inglese
moltissimi altri
ovviamente per depositare delle domande
di brevetto è necessario compilare dei
moduli in questi moduli cioè uno spazio
dedicato all'inventore cioè alla persona
fisica che ha ideato l'invenzione colui
il quale ha la paternità il diritto
morale sull'invenzione e che in quanto
titolare originario del brevetto può
trasferire a terzi il diritto di
sfruttare economicamente quel brevetto a
terzi che possono essere una persona
fisica o anche una persona giuridica ed
è colui il quale avrà il diritto quindi
di sfruttare il brevetto e col rayo
nebot ed è quindi compilare questi
moduli allora chi indicare come persona
fisica come inventore del brevetto della
domanda di brevetto avrebbe potuto per
esempio indicare i progettisti della
macchina dell'intelligenza artificiale
ma se io faccio una fotografia con una
macchina fotografica decisione diritti
forse dei progettisti della macchina
fotografica
allora avrebbe potuto indicare i propri
ha dei dati che sono stati immessi sulla
macchina ma i proprietari sono milioni
di milioni impossibile allora forse
avrebbe potuto indicare il proprietario
della macchina ma non era etico secondo
ryan e board perché non era lui ad avere
ideato e quindi indicare quindi ryanair
bot decide di indicare come inventore da
bus l'intelligenza artificiale che aveva
creato la macchina e come titolare del
diritto
il siero della società di reti neurali
che proprietaria della macchina ecco
tutti gli uffici presso i quali queste
domande sono state depositate hanno
rifiutato le domande di brevetto e tutte
sulla base della medesima motivazione
devo dire pendono ancora dei giudizi di
appello quindi vedremo come andrà a
finire ma sostanzialmente le domande
sono state tutte rifiutate sulla base di
due argomenti
il primo è che inventore può essere solo
una persona fisica e il secondo è che la
persona fisica cioè l'inventore non
avendo fin dall'origine la titolarità
del brevetto non può trasferire a terzi
il diritto sul brevetto il diritto
patrimoniale sul brevetto
ecco devo dire che queste queste
decisioni sono in realtà conformi alla
legge
c'è però da chiedersi se la legge è
conforme ai tempi se adeguata ai nostri
giorni
c'è da dire che queste domande
depositate da ryan e botha hanno avuto
il merito diciamo di scatenare veramente
un dibattito sull'argomento anche lo
stesso wipo world intellectual property
office che è un'agenzia delle nazioni
unite ha lanciato una consultazione
pubblica alla quale ha ricevuto oltre
250 contributi con soluzioni
assolutamente diverse tra di loro e
anche lo stesso giudice inglese ha
sollecitato un intervento su questo
punto da parte del legislatore ma siamo
poi così sicuri che la domanda
fondamentale sia chi è l'inventore può
l'intelligenza artificiale essere
considerata inventore in realtà essere
considerati inventore ci serve
soprattutto per dire che è legittimo il
trasferimento che l'inventore fa ad un
terzo del diritto di sfruttare
economicamente il brevetto ma se io sono
proprietarie di un albero in albero che
produce dei limoni e questo albero
produce finalmente i suoi frutti chi è
il proprietario dei limoni e se io sono
proprietaria di una somma di denaro che
deposito in banca e questa somma di
denaro produce dei frutti civili cioè
degli interessi in pochi per la verità
però chi è il proprietario degli
interessi
ecco allora allo stesso modo potremmo
dire che il proprietario della macchina
quindi dell'intelligenza artificiale è
anche il proprietario il titolare del
frutto che la macchina produce cioè del
brevetto quindi la vera sfida
io credo sarà quella di adeguare il
sistema brevettuale ha la particolarità
le peculiarità dell'intelligenza
artificiale
pensiamo alla descrizione un brevetto
per essere concesso deve essere
descritto bene fin da subito
bisogna dire qual è la soluzione tecnica
al problema tecnico come si arriva a
risultato finale
però i sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale spesso lavorano tramite le
black box
quindi io ho certezza dei dati che i
metodi nella macchina quindi dell'input
o certezza dell'output di quello che la
macchina restituisce ma ma non ho
certezza di quello che succede in mezzo
perché spesso la macchina lavora tramite
degli algoritmi che auto genera e che
quindi non sono neanche comprensibili
all'essere umano quindi quale soluzione
alcuni dicono che hai la soluzione è
tutto quello che deriva dall
intelligenza artificiale non è
brevettabile cade immediatamente in
pubblico dominio chiunque la può
replicare
eh sì però in questo modo manca
l'incentivo al brevetto e se manca
all'incentivo il brevetto significa che
anche le società che investono in
intelligenza artificiale magari
investiranno un po di meno
questo rallenterà l'intelligenza
artificiale da rallenterà il progresso
quindi non è una soluzione che mi pare
vada bene allora seconda soluzione
d'accordo proteggiamo quello che deriva
dall intelligenza artificiale ma con un
istituto giuridico diverso dal brevetto
che quello del know how del segreto
industriale
la coca cola ma
6 segreto industriale lo dice la parola
è destinato a rimanere segreto come
appunto la ricetta della coca cola
segreta da 135 anni e quindi la pepsi
non fa la coca cola nessuno sa come si
sa la coca cola e questo cosa significa
che mai la tecnologia entrerà a far
parte del patrimonio comune del
patrimonio di tutti mai potrà costituire
la base per altri studi per altre
ricerche per altri brevetti quindi
quindi anche questa soluzione non credo
che vada bene e quindi la soluzione il
brevetto il brevetto ma in un sistema
rivisto e corretto
ecco rivista e corretta esattamente come
bisognerà ancora studiare di battere
capire non è così semplice perché le
questioni sono tante quello però di cui
sono veramente certa è che si dovrà
innanzitutto che ci dovrà essere una
legge perché meglio una legge imperfetta
che un assenza di legge
in secondo luogo dovrà essere una legge
il più possibile condivisa da tutti i
paesi di modo tale che i paesi possano
competere su un piano di parità ma
soprattutto soprattutto credo che si
debba trattare di una legge che continui
ad incentivare l'uomo a pensare a
ragionare a capire a scoprire inventare
perché perché l'intelligenza artificiale
deve essere uno strumento per l'uomo
l'uomo deve sempre prevalere
sull'intelligenza artificiale del resto
chi ha inventato l'intelligenza
artificiale
ecco quindi che volendo un po chiudere
il cerchio in quel famoso libro oltre ad
un capitolo sulla persona fisica oltre
ad un capitolo sulla persona giuridica
inserirei anche un capitolo solo
intelligenza artificiale anche se quel
libro diventerà sempre più grosso un po
a danno degli studenti che verranno
grazie